[Music]
no and welcome to this video yeah this
is the video for the chapter on Benoni
systems yeah a Benoni
is on the board after this happens black
attacks the white pawn with c5 and we
advance the pawn to d5
in fact this structure is only happening
in this particular chapter
if black a text upon very early on with
c5 that means unmoved one like here or
on move to after Knight f6 Knight f3 c5
we also go d5 now why do we play d5 is
there some other way to play against
this early c5 we usually play with the
kingside fianchetto is that possible
against this early c5 um the answer is
no it's not this is in some way
unfortunate because it breaks them
typical pattern but on the other hand he
also probably should be he are grateful
that black is allowing us to gain that
much space early on d5 is just a strong
and good move and should be played we
need to be aware that black can also
play c5 at a later stage he doesn't
necessarily need to do it if he wants to
go in that structure in the first place
he doesn't necessarily need to be run
with one or move to there is also the
possibility that black is yam
first of all playing another pawn move
like a six or g6 and then play C 5 this
is indeed fundamentally different
because this would basically imply that
black plays c5 after he has played g6
and we have played g3 and that is a
really big difference because the benoni
structure with d5
is usually not that great for white if
we have already fianchetto wood this is
not I'm not saying that it's terrible
but in comparison we rather not want to
have the bishop on g2 in such a
structure as you will see later in a
typical structure like this quite often
we get to a position tab like that where
the bishop is actually exactly right on
the starting square it looks at crucial
squares like b5 for example when black
tries to play for the screen side
expansion the bishop is indeed better
here than on g2 and this means that we
will advance the pawn whenever we are
not committed to a king side fianchetto
that means like here on move to or at
the very beginning of their place he v
right on the second move
there's also no other alternative really
that would allow us to fight for an
advantage if we look at for example the
position here um I looked at g3 just for
ya being consistent but it is just not a
very good move because after g3 black
takes yeah we if we recapture we get a
bad reverse current felt because we have
not yeah made sure that black at least
has to spent two moves with the e pawn
or that he has to make some other
commitment please see the chapter on the
reverse rule that I think that becomes
more apparent then and like also cannot
wait here you cannot wait here for black
to play knight c6 because they have a
move like if I've to keep the pawn so we
are dealing with the situation where the
deviations are not great and the main
line like d5 here and what's also as a
response to one c5 is arguably a good
line for white so we should just happily
accept this invitation if we get to
situations with the pond
whoosh being delayed like here for
example this is a separate chapter here
we cannot even play the 5 because it
would blunder upon so these types of
benoni attempts later really are
attempts by black and they don't really
lead to Benoni and however - we only
have D 5 structures when we push the
pawn forward if the on push is coming
early on on with one or more - now after
that lengthy introduction let's have a
look
c5 is sometimes played on the first move
we push the pawn forward and now black
chooses between I can choose between a
couple of moves the only one that has
clearly independent value and it's also
sort of respectable is to move e5 them
so-called sometimes called would be no
Nia or Czech Benoni
black and with this move completely
closes the central structure and intends
to play form pawn pushes like f5 or b5
later it leads to a closed position very
closed where white or ever has more
space and an important point is that
let's put a form on the board and plex
t6 this is very logical an important
point is that we are not going to play
the move C form in such a structure
because c4 is a useful square usually
for night-night on c4 is well placed it
attacks the on d6 and supports f4 pushes
with pressure against a pawn on e5 so
make sure to avoid the move c4 it is not
helpful here at all
now here white has a couple of good
systems a good line for example here's
also Bishop to b5 check that is
recommended in I think more than one
book I however recommend to simply play
the Knight to c3 and later the Knight to
f3 a reason is that we can get this
close central formations also in
situations where we have
not they don't have the possibility to
play the check anymore for example like
would start with Knight f6 c5 g6 and
only later a5 what you need to see is
that it's most important here to
understand the typical setups and
maneuvers and then then you're good to
go
nobody already knows tons of variation
in such a close structure and so what is
blacks main idea here most of the time
black tries to exchange this bishop with
an idea like that Bishop to e7 Bishop to
g5 we've a look at that in a moment
sometimes however black is first of all
going from short castling yeah that is
also certainly possible I recommend to
just put the knight on the most natural
square Bishop to e7 and now the
important maneuver that you should
remember the knight is well placed on c4
so it makes perfect sense to immediately
go for that regrouping let's bring the
night to C form black castles and Bishop
to d3 you can also play Bishop e2 it's
also not a bad move but I think the
bishop here is well placed if you
remember that playing f5 sometimes part
of legs strategy we are looking to stop
that make it more difficult it's just
related to that e4 square now black is
most of the time still angling for this
Bishop trade we should cancel and black
plays Bishop to g5 now how do we set up
our position here I think that it is an
interesting idea to not allow the trade
of the bishops in the first place that
being said tonight c4 is not a bad move
here but I like to delay this decision a
little bit and see what black is doing
so I suggest a form this is a generally
useful move it makes b5 more difficult
for black we gain a bit of space is
generally useful let's say Knight to d7
and now interesting ideas to play the
move b3 somebody trying to put the
bishop here even on b2 and later maybe
try to prepare g3 and f4 for an
expansion yeah
in such a situation I wanted to show one
regrouping that black often plays in
such a structure that is the move g6 the
idea is to put the Knight to g7 and then
play f5 support this central pawn push
now here there's nothing particularly
wrong about other moves but I think him
the move Knight c4 makes perfect sense
trading those bishops now is a different
scenario because black has played g6 and
weakened his dark squares around the
King so trading this Bishop is now a
different kind of thing now after the
trade I suggest to take with the Queen
and our an important idea if they play a
five it is oftentimes the best reply to
just counterpunch with their form this
is also here nicely is supported by the
Queen er that can sometimes just be yeah
used on that diagonal in such a scenario
we are actually opening up the position
favorably while we have better develop
the future check this here black still
has those pieces round rather
undeveloped and the opening of the
center here with with the huge palm
tension here it's just in White's favor
because this is weak and this is weak
and those weaknesses on e6 and admit and
painters those weaknesses here are more
far more dangerous than for example
something like III which is technically
also weak but it's very difficult for
black to get there we are just closer to
exploiting those weaknesses
so keep the f4 push in mind against
blacks f5 idea
[Music]